walking on to this video playing
Maradona
this is Iceland know all and islands
yeah I keep forgetting that
yeah this guy is playing the the Kings
Indian it's play that the Arabic okay is
going with 97 yeah this is one of those
no community 7 interesting quickly try
to get an f5 yeah interesting if I
cancel long here yeah why not come on
Castle long f4 Bishop h4 s to get back
to f2 you don't want to allow him to
trade the dark squared Bishop easily
this is why I go Bishop h4 so that I
have Bishop ever to in case of a Bishop
f6 month yeah black here has closed the
the Kings side but not because he is
playing her for an attack but yeah I
cannot tell you why yeah I don't think
it's very good but what I'm getting at
is I'm still going to play on the Queen
side it just takes a takes a moment to
set up yeah before will come eventually
and black is not really able to to get a
King side attack going he can try for
counter play like he's doing but it's
not a King side attack that will
ultimately arrive
it's rather counter play against the f3
pawn for example um if I take he will
play f3 yeah not a good idea
I wonder still if I'm before I can
actually play before immediately yeah
come on let's do that very complicated
stuff 94 I take with the Bishop Andrew
k1 that's not a good good news and here
I thought rook gave one to have the the
pin he might still initiate counter play
with Queen h5 but okay b5 is a threat
for the moment so it's not clear if he
can really play directly on the yeah
this is this is probably probably right
complicated yeah maybe I miss time to
hold the whole procedure here are the
same night b5 I can still take and play
this this annoying Queen age 5 mm much
maybe I can replay Queen c3 to cover
that ir case his coming his starting
with the move Queen c3
23 is not possible unfortunately and
this looks kind of weird I hope I'm not
overlooking something here interesting
so what now
hmm
yawn ig5 is coming
I want a strange game yeah I don't know
a three-night g3 that thought the play
got got very serious quickly yeah
thought Queen f3 would be okay but maybe
it just retreats the Queen I'm not sure
that any that capturing yeah is so great
[Music]
yeah okay let's do it what I originally
had planned with all this operation this
this exchange psyched to get to c7
of course f3 hangs but I cannot really
play any slow moves and shuffle around
rook takes 97 is downright good for me
and pawn takes Knight c7 I thought that
maybe the pawn the pawn Messier can help
me
yeah Bishop Bishop to b6 I guess and
then c5 of course this is some this is
like yeah born out of necessity nothing
that was envisioned before and I had
this idea of the exchange sac but okay
that's a time where I would keep it
quick here and establish the pawn or not
I can also attack here attack b5
[Music]
hmm isn't this dangerous those pawns are
dangerous if his Bishop is pretty
useless in this position
[Music]
[Music]
if he moves the rope but in Nikon via he
has to give back stuff
[Music]
[Music]
the ship arriving on f5s is very
important
yeah Bishop age 4 Wow okay
about 19 seconds check
[Music]
check
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check I might I might make this check
check check check
very very close whew that was tough
that was tough I have no idea I mean he
got this I mean I really made I know I
know I know I made one very very
substantial mistake and this is here
here what what was a huge mistake
I should definitely play h3 sometime I
allowed this to happen and here instead
of moof like king king b2 or something I
should play this so that after a g5 I
have this and this is a totally
different thing because when he wants to
get in g4 he has to spend this kind of
moves and this is a big difference as
then the H fried is open and so on this
is a totally different and then I really
have some better chances on the
queenside it's it's very complicated I'm
not saying he's he's in terrible shape
or anything but this is what I need to
do this counter play was arriving so
quickly very difficult and I didn't want
to play passive moves
defensive moves maybe I need new to I
mean this is this this seems seems to
really not work
I don't know I I don't think that I
wasn't any any good shape here what
exactly is the comp giving here yeah
just a natural black pretty substantial
and she adds it's a win queen g6 is
stronger with 95 coming yeah yeah I know
I know my chief I haven't well this is
at least interesting it is it's not
sufficient but it it sets problems
definitely for black yeah it's hard to
ah interesting pitch after Bishop b5 the
the engine stock fish already gives use
white compensation with this 53 and
compensation like 0-0 evaluation that
sets curious yeah okay
it's it's a matter of our time probably
to get a decent evaluation like
something zero zero zero is hard to
believe I mean it should be good for
someone I don't know after Bishop f8 it
this is a winning for white yeah the
points are too strong probably I missed
some some quicker wins but yeah I should
force those through immediately probably
and don't even allow this but okay it's
a win I'm just a piece up here of course
this was already close to pre-move
territory but I think I can I kept stuff
together and what I overlooked something
it was always a win well six seconds
this was very very very close okay
thanks for watching